with very few pieces on the board mainly
and fishy-fishy
should not be satisfied with a small
advantage as Magnus did was yesterday
getting a small advantage playing for a
long time probably not really yeah
probably not winning but putting a lot
of pressure on your opponent is is fine
when you're leading in a match but not
when you're trailing so and what do you
think about yesterday's preparation do
you think that Fischer missed something
in the preparation because you when
you're preparing you don't really want
to go for worse positions no I I'm not
quite sure I think as the way it was
told to me because I did not attend the
French press conference basically the
question I was hoping somebody would ask
was asked of Ishii and he said no I
didn't know anything about any of those
things and Magnus sort of laughed out
loud he probably did not believe that
all that much and neither would I
frankly in his shoes I'm fairly sure
Vichy which is rarely completely
unprepared but whether we're exactly his
preparation stopped I have I have no
idea and we have and back to the Queen's
Gambit yeah you don't see it on the
board yeah but g5 has been played in
this position which seems to indicate
that 97 or actually there has been a lot
of analysis published on the events of
game 3 and some of it would suggest that
it's repairable that black doesn't
actually have to get the position he got
optimum of 25 and there are ways to
improve along the way and some of those
that's interesting no he's obviously not
sleeping but well a bit strange no I
mean it's it's ok but and now it's quite
clear that he was just thinking but you
know the first that very first frame
startled me a little bit Bishop e7 not
diabetes
7
you